at e3 2016 said that proyecto edge
showed off a brief glimpse of an
upcoming story mode for Gwent the tease
promised an isometric story driven
experience with a branching narrative
and disputes that were settled with a
round of Gwent it sounded promising but
after e3 the team went quiet in late
2017
said that project red finally released a
proper teaser for what we now know is
throne breaker a standalone Gwent
experience that follows not Geralt but
Queen Eve we spoke to said that project
read about the game recently to
understand more about The Witcher
spin-off it was decided quite early on
that we want to have a single-player
content for Quint because we this is our
background we know how to tell stories
so we wanted to use this opportunity to
you know tell a story for a different
game in a different gameplay context and
so two people were you know assigned to
sit down and start thinking about this
the first one was Mateos tomochka Beach
who was the lead quest designer for The
Witcher 3 and then I was the writer for
the project but initially when we went
to pitch that idea we were told to
prepare a proof-of-concept so obviously
we took girl because he's the character
who we are familiar with but it very
quickly became clear to us that girl
cannot be the lead character in a story
like this because girl travels alone and
here you beat a huge army and you're
supposed to you know put time and effort
into expanding ads and building little
in your camp and whatnot so girl was not
the the Wrights character here with
Geralt out said that Projekt RED needed
to find a character that meshed with
Gwent and the game's mechanics seeing is
you'll be commanding an army in the form
of cards it made sense to put a queen at
the center of the story below for your
sovereign Her Majesty Queen me Valyria
and Rivia and so we knew that we want to
start off with the northern kingdoms so
to tell the story through that
particular faction because I think it's
the most familiar for most players and
we're looking for the right character to
lead and and queen me does this
intriguing character it's mentioned in
the
books all her passages are probably two
pages when when you put them together so
it's not very long all the moments where
she pops up in the story really are very
memorable so we had these key moments we
knew that you know she lost her kingdom
that she started a guerrilla warfare
that she met Geralt at some point and
she prevailed and then this this battle
of the bridge and we knew that these are
all elements that we have to include and
basically we have to fill in the gaps in
between these key moments so we knew
that she was ASCII character we only
knew a little about what had happened so
we thought that this would be a great
character to start with and to take what
we know and fill in the details playing
as a queen is very different than a
Witcher this proved to be a challenge
for the writers but it allowed them to
flex their creative muscles in a
different way
the decisions you come across and the
characters you meet are very different
than the situation's Geralt would find
himself in the Duke of dogs fed you so
you've strength enough to carry arms and
as he gave you coin you've no need of
pay from the realms coffers sergeant all
men of fifteen summers or more will join
our ranks at once they'll serve five
years a girl does an outsider he doesn't
belong in the greater society he's not
respected by people they need his
services but they don't like him and
they want him to leave as soon as he's
done and he almost always travels alone
and he only opens up to his friends and
so on Annie was very different because
she's you know the queen of Libyan river
so she's respected and people bow when
they see her she has a massive retinue
of advisors and of the officers and and
and family that she has to interact with
and she has to think a lot about how
people perceive her so a girl you know
doesn't have to care about that he
doesn't give a damn what people think
about him but Mead knows that the way
she talks and looks is important to how
she's perceived and how her aims are
perceived so so there's this this
complexity this political aspect of it
that we didn't have to deal with when
were writing diodes for Geralt and also
since me this is the Queen whenever she
you know becomes impatient with someone
and just or you're her
soldiers to take someone and whip him
and basically push him off a cliff or
something your excuses I cannot accept
said the Queen the Vipers who called for
the slaughter they will hang so we tempt
the player to use that option so
whenever someone accuses you that you
were doing something that's wrong or
doesn't agree with you well you have the
option of just saying with this guy or
this is you know as much as they just
take me away and whether you use that
opportunity or not really defines your
version of me whether she you know how
open she is to criticism and so on and
like language wise we also knew that we
had to write dialogues a little bit
differently because Gerald doesn't care
about the etiquette he doesn't care
about formalities and even when he
interacts with monarchs is quite
informal but with me we knew that she
has to sound different so when she's
talking to people in like official
compacts she's very formal but when she
talks to her friends in the contain she
becomes this more honest more open
person so so she has these phases that
she either puts boots on on or takes off
so overall it was a very interesting
experience for me as a writer to come up
with different ways in which to portray
this character with the new character
also came a new part of the world over
the course of your 20 to 30 hour
adventure you will explore five
different maps there are five maps and
each of them shows a different region of
the witcher universe so you start out in
libyan Rivia but then you make your way
through the through the the northern
guam so you move on to Hedren which is
really ravaged by Wars and this is very
dark and and depressing landscape and
then you move to Maha calm so it was the
realm of dwarves that ever longtime fans
were you know dying to see and to
experience and we were finally showing
like how we imagined it and then is the
mysterious and foggy swamps of and guram
and finally we turn to trivia it's
fantastic to be able to go to these
locations also because I don't think we
would have to we don't think we'd be
able to show this much diversity in a 3d
we freely through play a game like like
The Witcher 3 because crafting locations
in a game like that takes a lot of
production
you know bodies and and with a TD to the
isometric game basically you can be more
symbolic and and and you don't have to
destroy everything literally so this
allows you much more freedom in how you
create these worlds so so I'm really
happy that we got to do that and I was
dying to you know write about maja
command and then present players who I
imagine that so when we decided we are
actually showing I'm loading how
important it is to to our a long time
longtime fans I spent months designing
this part of the witcha wall so I would
go through the books and find all the
relevant information and then I would
read about like what mining looked like
in the Middle Ages and how we could use
that knowledge to to represent my hakam
so we had these 60 pages long design
document outlining how it should work
out we also know that the dwarfs of my
hack I'm really isolated themselves from
the rest of the world and I really
didn't want Outsiders coming in so we
met into society which is very closed
and it has its own customs and values
and traditions that are not necessarily
easily you know understandable or
relatable to to outsiders and I think
we've created a really interesting part
of the witch world and I can't wait to a
players to see that and experience that
firsthand thrown breaker comes to PC on
October 23rd and Xbox one and ps4 in
December although many fans might have
their gaze fixed on cyberpunk 2077
thrown breaker is shaping up to be a
deep RPG that will give fans another
opportunity to explore the rich world of
The Witcher
[Music]